il est midi quand la délégation des 30
yvelinois mes pieds sur le sol
bruxellois parmi eux 17 élus et
représentants de missions locales neuf
étudiants et quatre lycéens
pas le temps de jouer les touristes le
petit groupe est attendu au parlement
européen par le député alain lamassoure
pour une leçon explicative deux ans sur
les nombreux jeunes climatique
ce voyage organisé par la maison de
l'europe des yvelines vise à
familiariser les jeunes avec le
fonctionnement des institutions
européennes
alors aujourd'hui j'ai vu le parlement
européen ensuite j'ai vu un dépôt un
député très été super intéressant
franchement j'ai beaucoup apprécié parle
avec lui on a pu prendre des photos
c'était super intéressant c'était super
bien l'avenir c'est les jeunes si les
jeunes ne connaissent pas l'europe s'ils
ne se sentent pas citoyens européens
c'est gagnera pas comme ça là la
bataille de l'europe quoi enfin je veux
dire il faut d'abord que les jeunes
sachent de quoi on parle quand on parle
d'europe
du côté des élus la visite est loin
d'être inutile il se met à jour sur les
affaires européennes
pour pouvoir s'en faire le relais auprès
de leurs administrés c'est intéressant
pour la compréhension des institutions
européennes pour la découverte pour
expliquer après aussi à nos concitoyens
à nous exactement ce qui se passe ici
comment les institutions européennes un
flux en direct sur leur quotidien
la journée s'est clôturée sur une séance
dédiée au comité des régions
la délégation a ensuite repris le chemin
de la gare pour rentrer dans les
yvelines
bilan quelques heures passées à
bruxelles auront permis de véhiculer une
image plus concrète de cette entité que
l'on appelle europe